plus de 35% des femmes sur la planète
ont subi des violences sexuelles au
moins une fois dans leur vie
je fais partie de ces femmes
j'avais 12 ans lors de nos premiers
viols et 17 ans pour le second
ces crimes furent une effraction dans
mon corps dans mon psy schisme ma
sexualité fut touché également mais il
n'a fallu de nombreuses années pour
comprendre à quel point et pouvoir être
aidées
mon corps est devenu un corps à corps
dont je me suis progressivement
dissocier
se réparer rejoindre le chemin initial
de sa vie tout en modifiant les impacts
de cette violence n'est pas chose facile
et c'est souvent un chemin de solitude
alors j'ai utilisé la psychothérapie
pour m'aider à comprendre
la psychothérapie mais du sens
stabiliser structure par la pensée
l'intellectualisation c'est indéniable
et ce fut vraiment important dans mon
parcours
pour autant il ya une absence terrible
dans cette approche
une notion essentielle et c'est celle du
corps le corps ça sensorialité sa
sexualité ont été bouleversés également
et nécessite leur propre moyen de
thérapie c'est de ce moyen de thérapie
du corps et par le cor dont je viens de
vous parler
un moyen que j'ai découvert et co
expérimenté avec un homme qui souhaitait
devenir accompagnateur sexuelle pour
toutes et tous sans distinction
son idée fondatrice était d'utiliser le
toucher grâce à des massages spécifiques
et de la sexualité pour nous permettre
de reconnecter à nos sensations
corporelles et à notre énergie sexuelle
l'accompagnement sexuel thérapeutique
n'existe pas dans le champ des thérapies
il est prodiguée pourtant des hommes et
des femmes accompagnent sexuellement
celles et ceux qui en font la demande
pour autant il est encadré ni par la loi
ni par un véritable cursus de formation
de thérapeutes
l'accompagnement sexuel dont on parle
dans les médias
et celui pour les personnes en situation
de handicap
c'est un sujet légitime est porté depuis
de nombreuses années par des
associations mais ce n'est pas mon sujet
alors quelle définition donner à cette
approche voici celle que je retiens
l'accompagnement sexuel thérapeutique
est un accompagnement la corporalité
incluant le toucher l'écoutent et la
sensualité c'est avant tout un soin et
un cheminement thérapeutique
alors à qui s'adresse-t-il me direz vous
les situations sont innombrables mais
pensez peut-être plus particulièrement
un adulte n'ayant jamais eu de rapports
sexuels à cause d'une trop grande
timidité
ou bien une personne ayant des séquelles
médical ou chirurgical ou encore ayant
suivi un parcours de transformation
sexuelle et devant investir de nouvelles
zones érogènes
penser encore à une personne ayant subi
in relation inadéquate avec un
partenaire ayant perdu confiance en elle
et bien entendu les victimes de viol et
d'abus sexuels en fait penser à toutes
personnes ayant besoin de renouer un
lien profond et étroit avec elle même et
n'ayant pas ou n'ayant plus un rapport
naturel à son corps et à sa sexualité
comment se déroule un accompagnement
sexuelle c'est la question qu'on pose
dans toutes les interviews
je vais pas vous décrire une séance type
n existe pas
c'est du sur mesure par contre il ya des
éléments communs et incontournable à
tout accompagnement je souhaite partager
avec vous
tout d'abord un cadre doit être défini
fixant le lieu la fréquence le permis et
l'interdît notamment
l'accompagnateur doit être le garant de
ce cadre c'est à cette condition
sinequanone que pourra se développer un
espace sécurisé tour de l'accompagner
dans lequel celui-ci pourra se déposer
se rencontrer
de plus chaque séance doit avoir son
propre cadre fixé à l'avancé
c'est une progression
ensuite c'est la question de la durée de
l'accompagnement
pareil elle doit être fixée au départ
mais réinterroger autant de fois que
nécessaire
attention il ne s'agit pas d'un sprint
aller trop vite peut réellement déchiré
le psychisme de la compagnie peut être
nécessaire d'y inclure des pauses les
reports voire des accélérations moduler
le temps j'ai vécu dans ma chair et en
os psychisme des effets néfastes d'un
rythme qui ne fut pas toujours le mien
et on remettra été compliqué alors une
fois ce cadre formel posée
questionné le consentement est l'étape
suivante le consentement doit être borné
défini expérimenté ressenti consentis
avant de démarrer l'accompagnement ne
s'agit pas de rejouer un abus de plus il
doit être interrogé plusieurs fois par
séance pour ma part mon accompagnateur
me disait que j'avais toujours le droit
de refuser même lorsque mon accord avait
été donné il me le demander de nouveau
et ainsi pu l'interroger mont houy plus
mon nom pouvait exister plus mon nom se
développer comme une certitude
inébranlable
puis je m'autorisais expérimenté et un
simon oui mon nom sont devenus ceux de
mon corps et le mcs sensorialité enoksen
ma pensée influencé par mes peurs mais
honte la moralité
quant au toucher à la sexualité ils sont
les outils fondateur de cette approche
ils permettent de réveiller nos
sensations corporelles voir nos mémoire
corporelle et les invite à s'exprimer le
corps et l'esprit sont enfin unifiée et
peuvent se libérer ressentir autre chose
que la terreur la souffrance d'un monde
dans chaque cellule chaque muscle chaque
sensation un masseur tantrique
m'expliquer que certaines personnes ne
perçoivent pas le toucher avec une plume
voyez le côté doux de la plume aucune
sensation par contre si les picotte avec
ses extrémités pointues il ya douleur la
question se pose pourquoi ressentir la
douleur et non la douceur comment
pourquoi avons-nous anesthésie à
l'intérieur de notre corps la sensation
de douceur ou était parti se planquer à
se cacher et surtout comment faire pour
la retrouver
abordons maintenant le sujet du rapport
sexuel je sais que c'est un sujet qui
est dérangeant qui vend des routes en
moralisateur certes c'est délicat mais
il est incontournable il est temps d'en
parler sans hypocrisie
et bien le rapport sexuel fait partie du
toucher c'est même celui qui permet de
se connecter à soi et à l'autre et de
vivre s'est ressenti c'est un véritable
outil et je la firme et surtout je le
confirme
pour ma part nous avons une sexualité
très riche avec mon accompagnateur mais
bien avant cette richesse nous avons
surtout abondamment parlé de sexualité
en prenant le temps en levant le tabou
toutes mes questions ont trouvé réponse
et ce fut fondateur de mon acceptation
pleine et entière
que ceux qui avilit un acte sexuel n'est
pas l'acte lui-même est bien ce que l'on
impose à l'autre contre sa volonté
je voudrais maintenant vous partagez
un moment cet accompagnement dont je
parle dans mon livre je suis quelqu'un
qui est opérée nombreuses fois et lord
anesthésie partiel alors que je sentais
mes jambes devenir inerte j'étais prise
de panique
un moment mon accompagne au vent étant
vraiment en confiance j'ai voulu aller
voir où j'en étais avec cette notion et
j'ai demandé à tester 1 notre sexualité
mais donc attaché il a mis tellement de
douceur de lenteur de délicatesse que
j'y rencontrais une profonde libération
vivre un moment d' entrave choisi est
consenti à pulvériser les chaînes avec
lesquels mais vient de me retenait
encore prisonnières j'ai pu remettre à
un autre les clés de ma sécurité est
entré enfin dans un dans une parenthèse
une bulle un espace intime dédié qu'à
moi
au cours de cette fois expérimentation
je disais que je ressentais mon adn se
modifier c'était ma perception celle
d'un mouvement subtil à l'intérieur de
moi celui d'une reprogrammation on adn
étaient modifiées je le sais je le
ressens
peut-être même être ce gène celui qu'on
transfère pendant trois générations
après un choc violent qui aurait repris
sa forme initiale en tout cas il me
plaît de le penser quoi qu'il en soit
aujourd'hui
bien des aspects de ma vie dans ma
sexualité ne sont plus impactée par les
effets des viols il aura fallu plus de
40 ans
vous l'aurez compris le toucher ce pont
entre le cordelle qui l'est au début de
la thérapie ce corps transformé à
l'issue de celui-ci de celle-ci par deux
le massage et la sexualité devient une
thérapie et permettent de se taire et
d'entrer en silence dans le temple sacré
qu'est notre corps pouvoir partir à la
rencontre de ce que nos sensations
corporelles voir le mémoire corporelle
ont à nous dire et puis magnifique des
voyages que vous ne ferez jamais
pas toujours facile mais tellement
libérateur
alors j'aurais pu vous raconter
l'histoire de ben c'est d'elizabeth ii
laurine de laëtitia
magali charlotte
vous aviez
christophe fabrice nicole julienne et de
tant d'autres et c'est avec mon histoire
plus illustre cette intervention
alors maintenant j'aimerais vous emmener
avec moi et essayer de vous faire
partager tout cas dans les sensations ce
que fut pour moi cet accompagnement
sexuelle et je vous propose mais à
écouter d'écouter ce que je vais vous
dire de vous prendre une position
confortable si ce n'est pas déjà fait
surtout de vous connecter à vos
sensations si pour certains c'est plus
facile de le faire en fermant les yeux
bien faites-le mais ce n'est pas une
obligation vous êtes prêts on y va
viens
viens pose toi tu as le droit de crier
hurler pleurer rêver aussi
désiré être désiré aimer et être aimé
pose ta tête sur mon épaule s'est tu en
ressens le besoin
qu'on vote des peurs regarde les hells
les partir poster honte et surtout ne
les reprend pas dissout en toi tout ce
qu'on t'a fait tout ce qu'on t'a dit
tout ce qu'on a fait porter et qui ne
t'appartiennent pas avec toi et danse
rit souris et jouit car tu es légitime
est sacrée et que tu n'avais pas à vivre
ce que tu as vécu
soit toi et s'est excusé ton corps
meurtri et beau tu es belle la
jouissance est belle tout comme ton
excitation tu es vivante et tu fais
partie de l'univers
apprivoise sa liberté femmes réalisé
rien et de ta faute tu n'es pas coupable
et puis surtout regarde-toi oui regarde
toi et sois fier la survivante
magnifique que tu es comme je suis si
fière de toi
je ne sais pas si vous partagerez mon
avis mais pour moi rien n'est plus beau
que de rendre à un être humain sa pleine
souveraineté alors nous dignes
descendants de descartes qui avons
appris je pense donc je suis rappelons
nous à chaque fois que nécessaire que
bien avant la naissance de la toute
première pensée tout notre rapport à la
vie et au monde se construit uniquement
par nos sensations je ressens donc je
suis sera donc ma signature et pour les
plus sceptiques ne soyez pas inquiets
cela n'empêche pas de penser bien au
contraire avec tellement plus de
richesses
merci
[Applaudissements]